oh whoa this is probably the best scene
from the entire movie one of my favorite
things about this whole scene is that hi
welcome back to another episode of
visual effects RS react we've got some
great clips free today one of our most
requested clips some really janky VFX I
can't wait to tell is oh you haven't
told me anything about this yet we've
got some real good jank in this episode
it's the best you don't know what's
coming
one of those guns last the guns possess
a need oh never have you seen this movie
No so magneto can control metal mount a
marvel day like that fluid simulation
he's got jokes do you see how the smoke
tracked on the gun when he moved it
there mm-hmm that was awesome there's
even like a vacuum behind where
Quicksilver is running and everything
kind of gets sucked into that as he goes
through it that's great this is probably
the best scene from the entire movie
doing slow-motion frozen slow-motion
scenes like this are actually really fun
and not that hard to do all you need to
do is have all your actors stand still
move the camera smoothly through them
and then 3d tracked the scene and just
add things to the air so that's why they
have so many different pots and pans and
vegetables and rain and debris and it's
all 100% computer-generated we actually
did this before in our frozen crossing
alpha video which came out like eight
years ago which is nuts
you notice how he's like running up on
the side of the wall there totally so
for here it's easy enough they just
filming him in super slow motion I hit
him with a super high powered air blast
fan but here they actually rigged him up
he's hanging sideways running alongside
that wall there that shot right there
how do you think they did that one this
strikes me as him running on like a
green treadmill and the cameras actually
sideways but then all the backgrounds
been replaced to make it feel like
Quicksilver is now sideways so that's
kind of it but his legs there are
interacting with the wall so they
actually did a full CG replacement of
the bottom half of his body what those
legs are CG legs adjust that tilted
sideways and watch it yeah you can
really see more obvious when you tilt
your head it really stands out when you
look for it now like the cloth there's
no cloth simulation and the motion feels
weird to me yeah that cheek shot like
when he taps the chicken so yeah that's
a really cool moment a really hard way
to do this is to remap 3d geometry onto
the guy's face reproject the image of
his face onto the 3d geometry and then
warp that 3d geometry and take the
lighting and the perspective shifts and
Comp it back onto his face the easy way
to do this is you just hit him with air
at like a thousand frames per second
another thing they did is formants
stabilization they have the people
staying there as still as possible but
even with
there's a little bit of motion and
they're basically going through and
freeze framing certain parts of a
performance and keeping it rock-solid
study having this sprinkler is going off
in the scene was a genius move on the
art direction by putting all this
particulate in the air you can feel your
motion through 3d space and you can feel
the frozen time can we do a quick
comparison to neo getting punched in the
face and slow motion oh dude that was
the best part of the whole movie dude
[Music]
that is sick so they're doing many
different things the same way for this
scene as the Quicksilver scene the most
primary thing rain water in the air for
one in Quicksilver they got the rain
shape right rain is not long it's
actually globular motion blurred water
droplet has a 3d model this is ballsy
those fluid simulations have for how low
res they are shows you like how
undeveloped that technology was but look
how good like this facepunch simulation
is
[Music]
Huey oh yeah I thought a dog
this is really intricate though super
intricate a lot of that stuff for actual
real filmed elements that are composited
in so this shot like this movie came out
very shortly after the matrix is
marketed as being from the producers of
the matrix from the producer of the
matrix it's like the next best things
The Matrix came out so this is them
trying to do bullet time but like it is
not nearly as elegant like it just
serves no purpose in the story like the
bullet time in the matrix like was
establishing how neo is seeing time move
at a different rate where this is just
like boy wouldn't it be cool to watch an
explosion in slow motion but hey look
they're doing some things right I'm
seeing some cool stuff right now like
you can see the explosion reflecting
through the water on the surface oh
you're right you look at that these days
this shot would be done like probably
all CG doing the people yeah but back
when they film this shot they were doing
the technique of basically yo-yoing
people or they'd wrap them up in the
cable multiple times and then yank it
they go boom they done whined really
fast and that's what's happening to all
those guys they're just being unwound
and they're flopping in the air and of
course they're doing into the green
screen so those are basically all just
like green screen elements yeah notice
you don't ever see a full car shot yeah
you never see that yeah you only ever
see parts of the car and that's because
they're actually being composited in so
they're kind of doing the classic cover
yourself a motion blur thing which is a
little disappointing because it kind of
makes this whole scene really blurry so
motion blur cannot be bigger than the
distance moved between frames so the
leftmost side of that rightmost spark
they go forward one frame so for that
motion blur to be longer than the
distance the sparks moves basically for
it to be overlapping itself for these
two frames it means that their motion
blur is higher than what a 360 degree
shutter would capture and it's
impossible for a shutter to be higher
than 360 degrees the third and sixty
degree shutter means it's been open for
the entire time your frames been exposed
a film camera can actually only record a
180 degree shutter and this is already
twice that for that spark so you're
saying that little strip of blur should
be reduced at having yes at least it's a
really complicated way of saying they
got too much dang motion blur in the
shop
interesting one of the big challenges
for visual effects back in the day was
high dynamic range imagery so for
example the explosion here the fire
it looks very flat the problem is you
know fire it's a very very bright thing
and when you have things like smoke and
dirt and dust in front of it it's almost
the same as putting like a neutral
density filter in front of your camera
which just cuts down the amount of light
in the scene now it's happening here is
that they're bringing the exposure the
fire down but the actual exposure is not
changing they're just changing the
colors of this blown out fire to begin
with so these bright white yellow areas
are now just dark mustard yellow areas
the fire is like way less bright than
the sky yeah it should at least that
bright this is a very big explosion that
go flying and the sky is the brightest
thing the reflection on the ground ocean
I remember this whole movie was marketed
on this shot alone was it pretty much
okay
if you guys have a specific shot for a
movie that you want us to take a look at
leave a comment down below letting us
know what that shot is who killed
captain Alex now this movie's got hard
hard
it looks like the fighting is actually
pretty rad these are some dudes out
there doing it because they love movies
and want to make one I'm so ready for
the shot anything big and important yeah
Oh
who made this that's what I want to know
there's a bunch of dudes out in Uganda
that just want to make action films and
just started doing it that's how we all
got into it yeah just do it just do it
this energy these guys are taking for
the performances it was like a rock
solid oh oh man did their best with that
track
I just stopped putting effects into this
part chopper I love it they obviously
don't know how to use an effects program
but it exists right of that they're
still making it a thing like they're
still making a film the most important
thing when it comes to visual effects is
making sure they are telling a story and
entertaining the audience if your
effects are distracting people and
pulling them away from like getting to
enjoy your story then your effects are
failing at the job but your effects are
enhancing it and getting people to be
entertained and getting them to like
your story then they're successful and
doesn't matter how realistic they are I
know we're being super like uplifting
here let's break down an effect shot and
talk about how we make it better I'm not
exactly sure what's even supposed to be
happening here did it land on it and
take it down all right step one
perspective making sure your perspective
is correct the helicopter is way too big
another thing if they want to make the
shot look more realistic without
changing anything else other than what
they're working with the black levels on
the chopper are way too dark you know
there's atmosphere between you and what
we're looking at here there's air and
there should be haze on the helicopter
and then hey you should make it match
the black levels so to speak of like you
know the windows and the shadows of the
buildings behind it take a little color
picker
what's the darkest pixel of your entire
shot and that should be how dark your
darkest pixel is on your renders I'm
just I still can't wrap my head around
the size of this helicopter and what
it's doing to this building yeah maybe
the concert or the shot in general is a
little out there hey in the last VFX
artists react I asked for your help to
get us three million subs and you guys
did it
thank you so much yes that's so cool
that's the coolest thing ever and I
promise you guys a cool party we're
gonna go get fancy sausages this Friday
it's gonna be the best sausage party
ever
mmm edge of tomorrow dude I love this
movie so much looks so good
one of my favorite things about this
whole scene is that this is the first
time you actually start seeing the
aliens and I think they have some
incredibly good character design for the
aliens that day leans just so me moving
they got the motion right in this so so
this is this is actually a great mix of
practical and CG stuff going on at the
same time they actually built an entire
Beach that they're blowing stuff up for
real launching practical missiles and
they lined it all with green screen and
then they're they're extending the set
just making it seem like this infinite
space it's just friggin d-day yes oh
dude when you said they had practical
missiles yeah we're kidding but some
probably a wire and then the basically
rocket hanging from the wire so that
they can direct the direction go oh it's
actually how they do aerials back in the
day to when people didn't get shot by
arrows it'd be a wire running to like a
plate on the person and they'd shoot the
arrow which is hanging from the wire so
to travel along the wire and into the
armored plate on the person that d-day
scene they're running through mud it's
water and mud it looks great on camera
but that is a nightmare to film in and
then you have to have these like real
mech costumes did you know that it took
like 30 minutes for all these guys to
get into these suits it's what Tom
Cruise did he was like I challenge all
of you guys who can get in their suit
the fastest and they got it down to like
three minutes and just by doing that one
little challenge Tom Cruise
single-handedly sped out of production
by like times 10 those suits are
incredibly heavy so for all like the
hero shots where they're having to run
with them they're actually suspended
from a crane just enough to reduce the
weight right so props Emily Blunt for
doing our own barrel roll this is the
movie that made me a huge fan of it oh
my god I like how her sword is CG by the
way so he doesn't accidentally clip
anybody with it just she just holds the
hilt and they put the blade in have you
guys seen Tom Cruise crashing the law
recycle and oblivion no that's Tom
Cruise right there boom oh my god he
almost got his foot ripped off
[Laughter]
you got so lucky my right leg is torn to
bits
and now costume change oh this movie
this movie has some really really cool
visual aesthetics I love like the sci-fi
aspects of this of this movie I love the
set that they made up in the heavens you
wonder why this looks so good
all those reflections are so perfect
like this would be a pain to Greenspring
with all those reflections mm-hmm but
look at the lighting it's it's so good
it doesn't look anything look like die
another day does it everything blends
perfectly you wanna know why everything
blends perfectly and everything looks so
good that's because there's no
green-screen that's because the
environment around this set the huge
dome projection they actually did a
projection onto a big sphere around the
set and they'd project the actual skies
around them so the lighting matched
their reflections matter that there's no
green-screen to pull and it just looks
so good that's awesome yeah they're
capturing real sunsets and sunrises all
of that cool looking scenery of the
clouds and whatnot is actually real it's
not generated at all I'm glad people are
combining practical and visual effects
because I think that's the best use of
both you know when they come together
and they work so perfectly together it's
awesome now we actually had the
opportunity to go visit the people that
actually made this screen two weeks ago
so they're actually doing some really
cool new technology now where they're
using LED screens instead of projectors
that they actually haven't rigged up to
the Unreal Engine yeah they're tracking
your camera in 3d space so as you move
the camera the background changes
accordingly to match the perspective to
your camera so it's Wow because everyone
else watching it it just looks all wonky
as like the image is just like changing
really weird what if you were to put
your eyes in the exact spot the camera
is it just looks like you're looking
into a new world
so we'll be actually dropping a corridor
crew video about that technology in our
visit there at some point the future
subscribe if you want to see it hey I
hear you guys like visual effects and
good for you we made a green screen
emergency blanket in fact we went out
and made an emergency green screen
t-shirt
Oh anywhere did you guys get the clean
plate cuz that otherwise wouldn't work
we also went out and made an emergency
mocap sweatshirt we made a 5 panel navy
blue hat two different colored winter
beanie hat we made a Nalgene bottle with
corridor digital all over it
no leaks no cracks just good
old-fashioned water container or
whatever you want to put in there heck
put a little beer in there you know I'm
saying and if you're into things that
are waterproof
we made an SD card waterproof holder and
we still have a bunch of black and
yellow classic corridor hats in the
store now if you like these videos and
you're interested in keeping some
awesome high quality clothes on your
body I would recommend going over to
corridor digital dot store it's right
there it's ready it's high-quality and
there's free returns so you don't have
to worry about not free returns thanks
for watching VFX artists react I hope
you really enjoyed it never Stowers
rated R we'd said we're gonna make it
well we finally did it's actually up on
the channel right now only 66 feels
pretty appropriate I think so like it
has it has a lot of hits we can all come
together and take a moment from that
that's gonna do I'll be one hitting the
rocks I'll do it all head getting shot
up so we all pick him home from the kid
shot alright guys we have work cut out
for us
you can go watch the video it's super
funny we had a great time baking it
thanks for watching guys leave a comment
down the description below
down in the description I don't do these
outdoors they're always bad but hey
heart two counts send a VFX shot that
you want to see us react to let's see um
it down in the description it you know
you know I'm saying
Star Wars rated R we did it check it out
it's gonna be sick I promise you